bienvenue à paroles autochtone c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine j'ai
aussi une question de isabelle qui me
demandent traditionnellement à ce que le
mariage existait chez les inuits oui le
mariage je pense que c'est une forme
d'union qui existe à peu près partout
dans le monde
bien sûr ça change de modèle chez les
innu particulièrement on se mariait un
homme une femme
mais ça valait pas dire qu'ils n'avaient
pas d'autre modèle d'union qui pouvaient
exister
il y avait des modèles polygame quand un
chasseur est extrêmement bon pouvait
prendre sous son toit
deux femmes se c'était habituellement
quand tu pouvais avoir la femme et sa
soeur pour pouvoir garder le campement
en vie parce que les femmes améliorer la
vie du campement mais les hommes eurent
ramené le gros gibier donc c'était un
équilibre qui devait exister entre les
hommes et les femmes parce que ça une
femme mais les hommes des fois même
devait faire campement entre eux et
trouvé que c'était très dur quand la
femme n'était pas présente pour
améliorer la vie du campement des
extrêmement bon chasseur près mais avant
jusqu'à trois ou quatre femmes dans
leurs campements mais c'était très rare
et ça voulait pas nécessairement dire
qu'il y avait du des activités maritale
qui se passe entre les femmes et le
chasseur souvent c'était un chef qui
allait prendre la responsabilité d'une
femme qui venait de perdre son mari son
chasseur réel et assurer la survie
justement de cette famille donc c'était
souvent des arrangements pour une
meilleure vie dans le bois en campement
mais il n'avait pas de calais pas
d'amour dé foi l'amour se découvre et
beaucoup plus lutter parce que les
arrangements des mariages se faisait par
les aînés ont trouvé à ce jeune là avec
cette fille ça va bien aller ensemble
bout mais ça voulait dire qu'on peut pas
tomber en amour qu'on peut pas m'arriver
bien qu'on aimait mais je veux dire
c'est comme toutes ont des fois on peut
choisir mal aussi une fête pour
s'assurer qu'une survie se fasse on se
fiait souvent aux aînés pour pouvoir
arranger les couples ensemble
même dans nos légendes on parle de
carcajou par exemple qu'il lui avait
deux femmes parce que quelques
ajustements été un très bon chasseur
pouvait se permettre d'avoir deux fins
il
c'est sûr qu'on parle même pas encore de
toutes les arrangements qui pouvait être
vie spirituelle c'est à dire quand deux
hommes s'est même quand deux femmes cm
il pouvait y avoir un campement qui se
forment
ça c'était beaucoup plus grand quand
même mais ça voulait dire qu'il y avait
un des partenaires qui prenait la
responsabilité de certains des rôles
qu'on disait traditionnellement des
femmes et des hommes
mais ce n'était pas lié uniquement au
sexe de la personne s'est élevé à la
capacité la personne alors des fois il
ya des hommes qui se blessait bien la
femme partait au coeur du campement et à
la sphère de la grande chasse parce que
c'était une question de survie de la
famille donc oui il y avait des mariages
c'était souvent facile de les défaire si
le mariage était pas bon et souvent les
jeunes filles bien juste avant de se
marier en profiter quand même un peu
mais ça je sais que ça l'avait choqué
beaucoup de prêtres et d'explorateurs
quand ils sont arrivés au québec et
c'est pour ça peut-être des fois qu'ils
ont un peu exagéré et laly perte de la
liberté sexuelle des femmes autochtones
mais je pense que c'était juste une
manière saine de vivre des relations
humaines
alors merci pour ta question isabelle
j'allais vraiment apprécié n'hésitez pas
à partager les vidéos n'hésitez pas
surtout à nous envoyer des questions à
espace autochtone